that is the band dnce led by former Joe
bro Joe Jonas and um it's like he
definitely has a thing for supermodels
well we were exclusively behind the
scenes of his new music video and we
asked him about his love life that is
when Joe wasn't making out with lingerie
Beauty Ashley Graham
Ashley's role is I guess my girlfriend
my new girlfriend Brown Ashley getting
steamy in her very first music video
locking lips with Joe Jonas 4d NCES
latest single toothbrush
I've been a fan since cake by the ocean
which I can't get out of my mind they
called me and asked me and it was a yes
I would love to be on it we talked about
your husband a little bit the last time
that I saw you is he worried at all
about this Yeah right with all my
sexiness everywhere uh-huh you can't be
with an insecure man if you're Ashley
grant while Ashley's happily married
Joe's love life is a little more
complicated
he's been recently linked to model
Juliana hers and his ex is Gigi Hadid
who's now with former 1d or Zayn Malik
rumor is Joe wrote about their split in
his music Joe you did tell us that when
some of your music comes out we will
know exactly who it's about how will we
know exactly who a song is about I
didn't say that
you should have somebody from you guys
yeah well let's check the tape once it's
out will fans know who it's about um
maybe I mean as of right now you
definitely will know who it's about
look I'm sure you know somebody's gonna
try to figure out something but
ultimately I do when we write music we
try to make it relatable to everybody no
need a question yeah that's what they
all say but moving on we found out Joe
has a hidden talent channeling his
brother sexy video moves and can do a
pretty good Nick impression oh please
see there's a camera though absolutely
I'm sorry I just can do a try but I'm
gonna see some Carey